good morning Millennials happy Friday
happy wedding special extravaganza I am
here with the bride herself Olivia
you're the really the bride now no you
could still hug please good please
welcome to the show oh my god thank you
so much for having me welcome back from
your honeymoon mini moon I know people
are taking umbrage with the fact that
you took a mini moon to st. Lucia so why
don't we do suggest that right off the
bat first of all how was your trip okay
my trip was [ __ ] awesome I'm sorry
for cursing it just like it needed to F
I mean that's the great thing about you
know what it's like that was like a time
to use it because it was so and you are
the most all the time no I know but like
most of the times it's gratuitous and
that time it felt really right I think
that's why I wanted to call out that I
used a curse word because I really
needed to anyways my trip was amazing
Zach and I are like fully planning to go
to Italy Tel Aviv for our honeymoon but
essentially he was able to carry a few
vacation days over into the new year
he's on wine ribs bachelor party so like
we weren't able to take off a week or
more in the beginning of the year we
wanted to get away for a few days
who knew that January first second or
like the two most expensive days to
travel so like we waited a little bit
January first I think we all we all know
that like January 2nd 3rd is the best
time no but like not coming home going
out still flights people might have been
in New York for New Year's even now
they're going home to st. Lucia totally
well anyways we decided to go to st.
Lucia because it was so freaking
reasonable the flight was amazing we
booked everything on points thanks to
the traveling toasters which is the best
group ever and they just give so many
good travel advice and tips but we
booked through Chase Sapphire and
essentially when you booked through them
and this is like not an ad whatsoever
but you get so many goodies and they do
like complimentary upgrades and like
they new is our honeymoon and so like we
lived the luxe life and if we just
totally fell into it it was so random we
booked it happenstance we're like let's
just go somewhere we've never been but
that's warm sunny beach drink food and
it was absolutely incredible like
literally the best of my whole life
that's amazing and to clarify it was a
mini moon because of the time you went
we were only there for four days right
that's not a honeymoon you guys so yes
she's a honeymoon destination but your
honeymoon should be at least a full week
I agree
and honestly I wish I could have taken a
honeymoon and I wish I could have taken
a full week we unfortunately could not
but I'm so grateful for having had the
mini moon because now it's gonna be a
while until we actually go on our
honeymoon probably end of summer so like
something to look forward to but it
along faraway yeah and like if you don't
I mean juries I trust that you guys will
take your honeymoon but a lot of people
who like wait on their honeymoons wine
I'm never taking them Claudian Ben so I
think it really is important to like
have a trip planned for after your
wedding even if it's not like the great
extravaganza that you have originally
intended totally and it's also so nice
to just get away after like all the
crazy planning which will obviously talk
about but like you go from such a high
high to honestly like a little bit of a
low because like you have nothing to do
I just can't wait for that low and you
think yeah I mean it's like okay now
what so like preoccupy yourself with a
pina colada on the beach have a good
time and like you're just like with your
husband like in pure and utter bliss
with like I'll think about anything else
in the whole world it's truly like the
best feeling ever right whether it's a
honeymoon a mini moon a vacation a
holiday whatever you freaking want to
call it do it right after your wedding
cuz it like it's I think it's so
important it like seals it all in first
sure anything you got a tan cuz you look
tan but maybe you just put on bronzer no
so chocolate at the beginning of your
makeup which I did as I always do but I
also did get a tan but it's probably the
first time in my whole life that I
didn't get like a raging sunburn which I
am she's growing up yep and so did use a
little sunblock your wife now you need
to use sunblock yeah
no Zach was like very like rigorous
about the sunblock and I'm like go away
I just find them to get burnt with
sunblock more than just like having the
first day you burn and then over time it
turns into a tan and then by the time
you leave the vacation look [ __ ]
awesome that's just that was another
important [ __ ] I'm safe oh yeah let him
find it's a web show but here's the
thing I have like more all of your skin
no pun intended
than you so like if I had your skin
complexion I would 100% oh there's my
earring again I thought that was an air
pod that just fell out of your you know
it's been like broken oh my god
and I just like wanted to wear it okay
well Jesus you're just casting pearls
here in the morning too
oh so be stylish I want air pod do you
have air pod I don't
they're amazing here's the thing I only
really want to get them because it's
freaking annoying as hell to plug in my
charger on my phone plug my headphones
and I'm like always trying to listen to
music always like never charge my phone
so I struggle I actually struggled
deeply with that on the plane yesterday
because I caught up on every single
episode of the toast in 2019 what you
think season to me season two yeah um I
thought it was fantastic like it was
just so funny and like so many things I
kind of know just like from you guys but
I like don't watch a show every day so
like divine diversion or like do you
know what it means like I don't even
know what these things are and then I
hear you talking about the allergies and
that's not a divine diversion and I'm
you know my New Year's resolution is to
try to watch as many episodes of the
toast and 2019 as possible just so I can
like know what the heck is going on
she's in tune you guys that is an in
tune resolution well we have a great
show for you today because of course
we're gonna hang it with the fat side
story so you need to numb free wake up
and take a bite of your morning toast
we're gonna ask all the questions that
you have for Olivia regarding her
wedding regarding some of the questions
that she couldn't answer on the patreon
episode and just you know lessons
learned etc and then we bring out Josh
from birch events design who designed
your gorgeous miss of a wedding that he
designed Claudia's gorgeousness of a
wedding and he will be designing mine
fingers crossed gorgeous missable
wedding honestly fingers crossed well
you don't even need it because when your
internship never made anything ugly in
his life they just can't jinx yourself
like no totally so I'm just
superstitious and delicious speaking of
people who are superstitious and
delicious Neffe smooches has been angel
boy at my house for nephews weekend out
and I just want to give everyone an
update say no ever I feel like
everyone's really invested in my story
yes they should be and they've been
there since the beginning where Zach
wouldn't even let nephew come over and
sit in the bathroom on a rug right so
we've really come so far he's being a
great angel boy no accidents in the
house so far knock on wood but it really
is so [ __ ] cold outside like I have
cracks on my hand from like walking him
and like being outside for so long so
you know I do it for the nephew well
getting stuffed in bed together last
night while he slept on the bed
on the outside of his outside though no
he slept straight in the middle like
just loveless I was curled up in a ball
but anything for the Mathew so it's
really funny because obviously Zack and
Zack are on the soccer party in the
Bahamas and apparently there's like cats
roaming outside the house and my zach is
like allergic to everything and allergic
to cats and was like panicky and I
wonder how your zach is handling that
given the fact that he also doesn't
always like the shedding of the dog oh
but they're just on the outside of it
yeah but like they were hanging out
outside yeah that's weird yeah I
wouldn't know because I honestly haven't
spoken to him okay when he like asked me
how are you doing I just sent my picture
of me and Theo and then he's like he
gets it it's also by the way that
picture that you took of me and Theo
yesterday that Kirk the Internet um
where it looks like I just gave birth to
him and it's my post birth hospital
shoot yeah it's just so precious and
really just sums up the essence of NWO
well to give a little context behind the
photo he was really into the shoot like
you weren't like holding his face or
what he had picked his head up like that
and was just like loving on you so and
we just captured a beautiful moment we
were like it was not staged whatsoever
no it's true because he doesn't pose for
photo said he doesn't to me and like
there are some photos of him with people
where he looks like so angry no totally
he has a very dynamic face he does very
a very expressive yeah he doesn't need
any like Botox or anything cuz he I
think like injects himself you know with
the Chapman style I of course he's using
his own medicine he's self-medicating
totally um so we're going into the
weekend together I'm a little worried
because you know that I love sleep more
than anything and he really is kind of
like I'm I don't think I'll be able to
sleep until 2 o'clock like I love to do
and like I really haven't slept well in
a while and I'm starting to break out
and I just know it's because of lack of
sleep mm-hm
so we'll see well two pieces of advice
on that one yes he will wake you up but
then you will go back to sleep too and
this is what I tried to start doing
before my wedding is drink like half
your body weight in ounces of water
every day I know guys know you don't
want to hear that I know and I certainly
did I already drink a lot of water drink
more I know but I drink a lot okay okay
are you ready for the past five stories
that you need to know
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I'm ready yes I'm ready I
feel like a lot of things are going on
yet there's a lot of different stories
that are brewing so a couple of our
stories today our stories that are
updates on stories we've been talking
about all week um the first story though
Lindsay Lohan denies Jax Taylor hook up
okay so Lindsay Lohan was I'm watch what
happens live with Danielle Staub on
Wednesday night and first I watched her
show and then I watch the episode of
watch what happens live and I have so
many thoughts on Lindsay Lohan but first
and you played plead the fifth with
Lindsay and they asked her like a really
it was a waste of a first question
honestly in the way that they asked it
was like so stupid they had Lisa
Vanderpump make a video for Lindsay
saying you've hooked up with Jax Taylor
described your and described him as a
sexual partner in three words which like
is lame as hell but then Lindsay said
that she's never met him so I don't know
this has been like a running story for a
while that Jax and Lindsay hooked up so
this kind of like because he's older he
was really in that Hollywood scene like
back in the day so it's he's kind of
like one of those and I could totally
see it happening cuz he's been on the
scene for a while but for her to just
burst our bubble like that so this is my
two cents on it it totally happened
she's a thirst monster she knew if she
said to the contrary someone like page
six was gonna write it up I'm right now
she's trying to get promo for her show
so she's just trying to keep her name in
headlines listen we've all read the
blinds about her we know that she has no
problem hooking up with everybody Under
the Sun so she really has no reason
coming tonight waiting well here's what
I think I don't think either of them are
lying this is what I think happened
Jax is twenty-something in the clubs
Lindsay Lohan's there they probably made
out or something because that's what
like hookup means he says he doesn't
have to describe him as a sexual partner
like Lisa like right I can't
he was tender they totally like made out
in the club yeah Jax realized he's
hooking up with Lindsay Lohan but
Lindsay Lohan is like I'm hooking up
with the bartender in a club she had no
idea he was by the way one he was
chasing back then q I'm sure like this
was a crazy time for her I'm sure she
had no clue he was in nobody so why
would she remember him yeah I know he's
my point varial wasn't so she probably
is like doesn't remember because he was
not memorable because she was the star
and he was the nobody yes
100% definitely a possibility I have not
watched her show and I don't plan to but
the only thing that I've heard about it
is that it's like the grecian Vanderpump
rules and so if you are talking about
the star of your biggest competitor show
I just think she's trying to start drama
and she's doing it for the press circuit
it did it this is like makes no
difference to her whether she or not she
hooked up with him and she's literally
just creating a story in my opinion okay
well I did watch the show and yes it is
very much modeled after Vanderpump rules
but like here's it's so weird because I
still don't understand her because like
for so long I just thought she they
completely lost her mind and like you
know she makes that video of like her
trying to like rescue some refugees who
like didn't want her like it's just
messy as hell yeah with her fake accents
and then this show comes out and like
she seems like she kind like she knows
what she's doing like she has a plan she
goes when watch what happens live she
was very like with it in China making
jokes she was like shading ding I'll
stab like thing else tablets the crazy
one in the room and I was like kind of
impressed by her but I just I had
totally written her off you know yeah so
it's like she hasn't lost her mind
she seems to be okay uh the show is
pretty good the first episode was kind
of messy and like I had some issues with
it but it was like the pilot of anything
you know and it's on MTV so yeah
whatever but like the cast was it's okay
it has potential it has potential I
think she's just weird like think about
how she grew up she's like thrown into
the limelight she's like the biggest
star of our generation as a kid and like
she just combusted like so many of them
combusted not Hilary Duff but like the
Papas either Hilary Duff or Lindsay
Lohan I think she's just a weirdo like
she definitely and probably drinks a lot
I mean I listen to the Joey episode
yesterday where he said he met her at
the launch party and like she the photo
was that her was Adina that was her that
she was right photos like she she wasn't
doing on the show
I don't know shoot ringing out much when
I'm inside I'm not sure if she's sober
cuz like she's had she would have a bar
race issues before yeah but like
sometimes it's like Deacon Claybourne
like owning a bar really got him in
control of his alcoholism right right
right
no totally I just think that she knows
how to create press she wants to create
press around her show and she's freaking
weird yeah she's
weirdo it's it's interesting I'm I will
definitely continue to watch her show
see where it goes and and and I've heard
really good things about her Club
I was watching daily pop and Justin said
he went to her club when he was in
Mykonos and he had the best day of his
life
really yes so why did I fun as hell but
I did read a blind that it was not gonna
be open next season oh well maybe it was
just for the show then maybe yeah okay
how could you have a bad time in Mykonos
no but like some clubs are better than
other clubs and he was like it's not
like they he said we were gonna go you
know have a drink lol yeah and he had a
great time so like how people go to sur
and pump and and then they have the
night of their lives okay next up in all
in today's update of our Kelly news
since the documentary has come out uh to
two important updates first I saw this
story and I just had to share because
it's just sickening are Kelly's streams
increase after docu-series alleges abuse
Nielsen music says streaming numbers
doubled streaming numbers for our Kelly
have nearly doubled after a recent
documentary accused the R&B singer of
sexual misconduct involving women and
underage girls the lifetime doctor Cerys
surviving our Kelly detailed abusive
allegations against our Kelly in six
episodes but the singer streaming
numbers grew significantly during and
after the series his music streamed
eight hundred and seventy thousand times
On January 2nd the day before the
premiere but Nielsen said Thursday
Kelly's music garner nearly one point
seven three million streams after the
sixth episode aired on January 6th I
mean this is deeply upsetting I guess
technically makes sense because if
you're watching the document say like if
you're watching the documentary they
talk a lot about his songs and how they
spoke to the era and the state of mind
that he was in so someone might go and
listen to that song they also talked
about songs this was the best song he
ever wrote or this was the worst song so
they might go be listening one to hear
the lyrics again like we're missin - I
admit and listen to all the lyrics or
trapping the closet to give some sort of
context to the time what everything was
happening yeah
I mean I also like I didn't even
remember that he sang I believed I could
fly so I feel like I would have been one
of those people who
like went to Spotify to just look at
what he's saying but that's part of the
problem why is he still on Spotify I
will tell like that he should be removed
from Spotify he should be removed from
YouTube he should be removed from iTunes
like this is there's so many problems
with this and I haven't seen it and I
almost feel like I don't have to see it
because what we're seeing right now is
this is systemic right it's happening
every which way the fact that Bohemian
Rhapsody won a Golden Globe for Best
Picture when Bryan Singer was the
director and has horrible allegations
against him number one
number two was fired from the movie
literally at 90% of it being completed
but that's not the point like that's
better than him you know working on a
film that should then be awarded
accolades in my opinion like that's the
problem with everything well there's so
many problems I wouldn't say this is the
biggest one but you're just continuing
to fuel the fire like I heard that
there's gonna be this like huge like
banner poster flying over the RCA
Records office in LA
like mute or Kelly could be take down
his music take down anything that is a
revenue generator for him all these
companies all these brands are always
taking a stand they always have opinions
on everything and they make commercials
and this that and and drop this one and
that one cancel culture period but like
when it comes to these horrible
offenders nobody is cancelling them
right but here's the thing it's it's a
two-way street because one yes he
shouldn't be on Spotify in streaming
services he shouldn't be able to make
money from his music anymore but it's
also on us well not me because I didn't
go listen to his music after watching
you that matters I didn't but it's on
the people the people are keeping him in
business the people are listening to his
music okay say they take him off of
Spotify he put up I admit on soundcloud
like anyone can upload anything to
SoundCloud and if people go and listen
to it you are the problem so it is the
powers-that-be 1000 per day and they've
been protecting him and they can do more
to cancel him but it's also the people
who went to his show two nights ago in
Chicago agreed sold out people waiting a
lines down the streets agreed but also
one eye 1 million percent agree with you
but there's also like two different
types of people there's like media
elites that
how we should feel about everything how
we should think about everything and
then there's just like pure fans who
maybe live in their own bubble and so I
feel like from the higher-ups who are
always telling us like you know what we
should think about things and you know
what's the best movie and they said like
people are so concerned about Kevin Hart
not hosting the Oscars like I I really
think that we should be focusing on
those people who are so fixated on that
should be focused on this right like the
people who are worried like ants like
haven't Hartford things that he said
versus are Kelly for things that he did
and hurt so many people that he is doing
right by doing there's a difference
between saying something and doings and
hurting someone a million percent and
people don't seem to understand that
here's the thing and even if we want to
equate the two then treat both equally
if you cancel one cancel the other I'm
not eat don't eat like it's just it's so
crazy no I'm not saying that you should
I'm just saying it's so hypocritical
yeah but then okay here's Kevin Hart has
a movie coming out today the Bryan
Cranston one that looks so good I heard
it is a Miramax film that's well
Miramax is Harvey Weinstein's company
let me just double check what it is
Harvey Weinstein Company but what I
would say is was it it's so fishy like
was it sold and who runs it now and are
the people in charge decent yeah right
because at the end of the day you could
say that about the other side right like
Bohemian Rhapsody was produced by 20th
Century Fox Fox is ginormous
conglomerate right like I don't know I'm
just going to double check on that but I
heard a non-daily pop it you know they
have to fact-check their sources tip no
I believe that that's true it's just
more so did they start the production of
the movie with Harvey Weinstein in power
at Miramax if they did in my opinion
that movie's canceled if they didn't and
this business that employs thousands of
people who work in entertainment who
loved their job and loved the industry
that they're in thankfully get a new
life after that bastard was kicked out
great if they're making a great movie I
can get behind that okay this is what
I'm DB says although the film was
originally developed and produced by The
Weinstein Company and still credited as
such in the version of the film that
originally premiered at the Toronto
International Film Festival in 2017 the
companies in Harvey Weinstein's credits
as exactly
producer do not appear in the theatrical
version due to the bankruptcy of the
company in the sale of the film to STX
entertainment okay so Harvey Weinstein
made the movie yeah and then he sold it
but did he and he made the movie prior
to these allegations like this is not
that I'm a I'm not trying to equivocate
I'm just saying like a lot of people
worked with Harvey Weinstein before it
came out that he was a bad man just
saying honest I hear you
I said like why does Harvey why do you
have to ruin a good movie like I still
want to see the movie I mean he ruined
many a good movie I know he made
everything for sure but and if we don't
see and you know that there's like a
whole I don't know if it's party that
sold it so even if you go see it it's
not money in his pocket right but if you
read the blinds when it comes to award
seasons and Harvey Weinstein he used to
like literally everybody who ever won an
award at award season in the last like
15 10 15 years like was significantly
paid off by Harvey wines you know there
was huge campaigns around it he was like
a machine so I honestly let's just
cancel he's [ __ ] a [ __ ] it shows
there's such garbage there's such
garbage in the garbage they are still
like everyone used to think Harvey
Weinstein in their speeches and now you
know those haven't eat well but even the
speeches that people are doing now this
year last year and the people in the
crowds who are like when they're you
know up there talking about you know
getting the industry to not be like
Satan's den there are people in the
audience who have been accused of such
things
and if you read lines do those things
right so it's just so hypocritical and
then they just sit right there like
smiling and they're welcomed with open
arms and they win awards and they get
front-row seats and it's garbage yeah
who I'm I do have someone in mind that
you're thinking of don't you don't have
to say I don't particularly technically
slam them I don't particularly because
to be honest with you I have not been
able to get over that bohemian rhapsody'
won Best Picture at the Golden Globes
like that is so vile to me I can't even
begin and I feel bad for everybody rami
malek and everybody who worked on the
movie who is probably a lovely person
but my god I need take a freaking stand
that's just for Mike Myers where is he
I mean he's around ish
he took a really long break like no
one's act like wondering where he is
yeah but then he showed up in Bohemian
Rhapsody I love him so much
oh dude hey hey I feel like you would do
you have an Austin Powers poster in your
apartment yeah we have kind of Austin
Powers opposed to it we bought it when
we were drunk and then it like a ride
that was like that was stupid but it's
kind of cute oh my god whatever I know
by the way I really liked it like I
remember it and I'm like don't you have
it it's memorable that's for sure yeah
okay second part of our Kelly update is
that his daughter has released a
statement condemns him as a monster amid
allegations buku Abbey the estranged
daughter of art Kelly's speaking out
amid allegations against her father
taking to her Instagram story she wrote
buku here I just want to say a few
things before I start I just wanted to
be known that I'm speaking from the
heart nothing I say or do not say is to
hurt any party reading this are affected
by this to the people that feel I should
be speaking up slash against everything
that was going on right now I just want
you all to understand that devastated is
an understatement for all that I feel
currently I do apologize if my silence
to all that is happening comes off as
careless that is my last intention I
pray for all the families and women who
have been affected by my father's
actions trust I've been deeply affected
by all of this so the statement is
longer but you know she's obviously I
can't even because not a girl has I've
been through so that family that mom and
the kids like and to be honest II
haven't seen the documentary so I don't
really know that much but you know
they're estranged for a reason and I'll
leave it I thought first sure yeah I
mean yeah I don't think anyone was you
know blaming it's everyone wants like
place lemond everyone except the person
himself you know right like oh where
were you where where was he where was he
yeah okay next story just is similar to
the are Kelly drums Michael Jackson's
estate slams documentary about his
accusers so there is a film called
leaving out leaving Neverland which will
premiere at the Sundance Film Festival
later this month it tells the story of
two men now in their 30s who had
long-running relationships with the King
of Pop at ages 7 and 10 the late stars a
state blasted the film as quote yet
another lurid production in a statement
Wednesday this so-called documentary is
just another rehash of dated and
described discredited allegations it's
baffling why any credible filmmaker
would involve himself with this
I check the statement said I mean this
documentary is long overdue yes I look
forward to another documentary coming
out here serving up justice even though
you know it's posthumous justice I hope
there are a lot of people involved in
what was going on with Michael Jackson
Neverland a lot of creeps who are still
working today so I hope that this
documentary sheds light on what did
happen is that kali Culkin in the movie
um there's especially a lot of blinds
about this too but Leon had he's the
only person we need to hear from well
there's a I just hope that this
documentary like sort of exposes more
people who are still doing horrible
things and still working today you know
so that we can we can do like so that
we're not can be cannot everything is in
hindsight you know like oh it's easy for
all of us to like talk [ __ ] when
someone's dead but like do something
about it fire someone totally I totally
agree
so I'm will be the first one in line
watching this documentary and any others
I mean anybody want to make any
documentarian I think that's the word
that wants to essentially put themselves
out there to create to create
documentaries or docu-series like this
that are maybe kind of like unpopular
difficult will get a ton of backlash
from fans and all I'm I stand behind you
100% totally tell the stories we're
listening okay
next update of a story that we've been
talking about all week is the woman in
the coma who gave birth I was in an uber
at 5:30 in the morning go into st. Lucia
I'm a mini moon and I turnt it I was
like on my phone I turned to Zach I'm
like do you want to hear the weirdest
friggin story and I literally read the
whole article to him and we were so
confused and then like it was in the
sisters chat a couple hours later when
everybody woke up and I was like I
literally have not stopped talking about
this story there's so many things about
it that we just we can talk about it all
day so sickening but here's the latest
update woman in coma who gave birth had
been in nursing facility since she was a
toddler according to court docket ativ
state who gave birth to a baby boy on
December 29th has been at the Phoenix
based nursing facility since she was a
toddler people confirms records obtained
from Maricopa County Superior Court
state the woman has been a resident of
the facility run by Hacienda health care
for more than 27 years nearly double the
length of time that appeared in previous
reports the patient who has been
identified as a 29 year old Natan Native
American has been under the care of the
facility since she was between the ages
of 2 and 3 according to court documents
which also state that the woman suffers
from quadriplegic recurrent pneumonia
and a seizure disorder right quote she
lacks sufficient understanding and
mental capacity to make decisions or
give consents for her medical placement
or financial estate also I had read that
there hadn't been a check a doctor
hadn't checked on her Wow a doctor
hadn't checked on her in eight months
which is why they did not know she was
pregnant
one sickening disgusting - I had heard
that I guess as a toddler maybe she
drowned and I think that was the reason
for her being in a coma and I also think
that the aspect that she is Native
American is so interesting because
typically I mean not typically I we
could have this conversation all day but
if you were in a vegetative state for 27
years
like would you want to be in a
vegetative state for 27 years right yes
I said yes they have specific I don't
know if there's like either cultural
things in the Native American community
or otherwise where you know just
regardless you just keep the person
alive with the hope that you know one
day something miraculous happens I
wonder like because you don't really
know the state of that person but like
has she been in pain for 27 years like
right all of these crazy things so I can
imagine being pregnant and being in a
vegetative state was incredibly painful
and I don't I don't know I don't know
but her family didn't visit her for
eight months
apparently the facility that she's at is
like a hundred plus miles away from
where she's from I read that it's
somewhere I don't know if that's 100%
true but it's in Phoenix and her family
I think lives further away mitches maybe
why they don't come to visit as often
because it's just a further drive yeah I
mean but only seven years
you might go eight months right and also
I'm assuming that's extremely expensive
27 years of care yeah I mean they're not
caring for her which is horrendous
somebody is that taxpayer dollars like I
mean her family's probably paying for it
yeah and they should be refunded in
addition to a lot of other things
anyways it's just it's really crazy the
the fact that she's been there since she
was chu like imagine if the person who
did it like his I know I assume that she
has been I mean I don't want to make
assumptions but I would assume that she
had been assaulted on many occasion
right yeah well we'll continue to update
you because this story is vile and such
a sick world shocking sick world
speaking of stories that we've been
keeping up with for years now and the
sick world that we live in
exclusive quote I killed Jon Benet
Ramsey convicted pedophile Gary
Oliva has confessed to the murder of six
year old pageant princess in prison
letters to his friend claiming it was
quote an accident Gary Oliver 54 has
long been a suspect in the murder of
jamun a Ramsey whose body was found at
her home in Boulder Colorado on December
26 1996 in letters to high school
classmate Michael Vale obtained by D
Daily Mail TV
Oliver claims he killed Jon Benet by
accident quote I let her slip and her
head bashed in half and I watched her
die it was an accident he wrote from
Lyman Correctional Facility Colorado
Oliva is serving a 10-year sentence for
possessing child pornography when Oliver
was arrested in 2016
police discovered he had 335 photos of
Jon Benet including photos from the
six-year-olds autopsy they'll 55 up in
Tora California has urged pleas to
charge Oh LaBeouf for JonBenet's death
since all of us due for parole in twenty
twenty shillings a bail tells Daily Mail
TV then on December 26 1996 all of I
told him quote I heard a little girl
investigators believe several men were
involved in Johnny's death and bail
hopes Oliver will identify them the
incriminating letters have been
presented to Boulder police and murder
case investigators are now looking
through the new information this is
shocking yeah a lot of people have
confessed to JonBenet's murders has
anyone who's actually
a suspect convinced confess so I don't
know but I want to say a couple things
cuz I knew this was gonna be a story and
so I did a little bit of research thank
you and so a couple of things that are
important to note JonBenet Ramsey's
autopsy said that she died from blunt
force trauma and asphyxiation okay
mm-hmm her slipping
okay bang to the head fine the
strangling part don't know where that
comes in maybe she was being strangled
and she slipped I'm just trying to like
deduct here one - apparently - they
exhume the body like maybe a couple
years ago and have two male DNA samples
that were not matched to anybody in the
family which i think was when finally
the family was cleared and so I would
would suspect that they should test this
guy's Gary oh lavas DNA - those samples
however if he is incarcerated currently
that means that his DNA is in the system
and so it would have come up when they
there could have been other men there
and then he could have been one man why
were there other men in the house
remember at the end of the day this was
in her own basement and everyone was
sleeping upstairs like how did all this
commotion go I mean he had pictures of
her like I I read and I this is
conspiracy to the max but there was a
hole thread in one of the toasters
groups about the dad's business he sold
his business to Lockheed Martin Isis Abu
Baba whatever and the point is is that
some of the people who worked at
Lockheed Martin were bad guys and they
were part of a pedophilia ring and
bah-bah-bah but at the end of the day
there were here's what we can deduct
there were multiple men in her home in
the basement and this guy Gary Oliver
had photos of her he is probably not the
only person to have had photos of her
and there was she must have been you
know part of some sort of like child
pornography ring and I don't know if it
was happening in the basement of her
house or otherwise but that in my
opinion is like the only thing I can
deduct from the facts number one
number two it is important to note I did
not even realize that JonBenet Ramsay
died in 1996 Margo ASHRAE was not even
born yet
yeah that is incredible but it was so
long scary this is for some reason I
really like I believe like when I read
it I really thought that this was it you
know I think this guy definitely had
something to do with it I think there
are multiple people involved but that's
a major lead hundred percent so I hope
that you know some justice begins to be
served from this a lot of people have
confessed but like they were people who
had who couldn't have even been there
right now so well it kind of when I was
thinking about just it happening in her
basement and kind of gave me Elizabeth
Smart vibes where the family had like
let someone into the house right to do
work and where it's giving somebody an
opportunity and obviously he was a very
bad man and took advantage in a horrible
way but I wonder if this was a similar
situation I wonder if the Ramseys knew
Gary Oliva I wonder if they're related
to Mason Ramsey oh my god plot twist
also three out of the five stories today
have been about pedophilia and I just I
think that that is just a sad statement
for it's indicative rapport specially
for a show that um really tries to like
stay above you know and light news it's
like we can't even get there well
because there's just so much nastiness
going on in the world like that is so
sickening three out of five are about
pedophilia and then the four out of five
were about assault yes and what I was
surprised that you did not have as a
story so I will say is a complimentary
sixth one is that Tim Tebow was engaged
I know but then it's like I almost did
it it's like just like so random at that
point you know what is there to say like
Congrats
like I hope you enjoyed losing your
virginity and like go forth and prosper
totally and she's very pretty and the
pictures were lovely and it definitely
gives me like a little bit of like a
Priyanka Nick vibe in terms of same
photos similar caption very staged but
you know what I'm here for everybody's
happiness so Howard have you definitely
here for the happiness of Tim Tebow he
really does
you know he's like really can't had to
break these days can't catch a break
this obviously seems actually a break or
he's reporting right I mean he was in
the NFL then I think he was in the MLB
then look I think he does a lot of
charitable work he's just a lovely human
being from what I can garner about him
and is extremely good-looking so ah yes
I mean you guys know that I love him so
you know leave it at that I'm happy for
you you know I found my own happiness so
I'm happy for you and you know made me
see you at the Super Bowl
um okay now for a little lighter news I
just can't tonight on next week just has
to be like happier you know these heavy
subjects it's a lot to start your day
with you guys like we totally do like
the onion type vibe where you like make
up fake stories that are like so
hilarious and outrageous you know
they'll be so funny yeah we don't even
have to because the world is like just
do it on April Fool's Day like just do
one whole episode of like you know fake
stories fake news fake news okay now
we're gonna get into Q&A with you we
have so many questions for you oh my god
ask away the wedding extravaganza so a
few things I want to touch on that you
couldn't talk about and in during your
peach run episode what song did you walk
down the aisle to what was your first
dance song okay I walk down the aisle to
I actually shared this on the patreon I
think the Hebrew version of Bowie Kalla
which is like here comes a bride to the
tune of hallelujah by Leonard Cohen
which was very moving I wanted the
ceremony to be really moving I wanted
the music to be moving Zach walked down
the aisle to an instrumental of what a
wonderful world which is one of his
favorite songs and he does a wonderful
Louie Armstrong impression and then
sisters walked down to a musical
interlude or instrumental interlude I
don't know of somewhere over the rainbow
which is just a beautiful song that I
love and we had actually started before
anybody even came out we did like a
Hebrew rendition of laqad OD to all of
me by John Legend to really kind of like
bridge the English and the Hebrew we did
not have like a lot of people walk it
was just sisters and family but it was
just so lovely and beautiful and that's
exactly what I wanted
tell us about your process or your
progress with the live method happily
okay
so for my wedding I lost about 48 pounds
I really wanted to hit 50 but didn't
happen for me and I started working out
the live method in October I had just
kind of seen on Instagram everybody that
went there just looked amazing but
everyone was like so like enjoying the
workouts and like what they got in
really great shape and I was just like
you know what I had lost about 20 or so
pounds before I went to the live method
and I knew that I had to kind of like
accelerate what I was doing maybe start
working out I knew if I kind of did it
on my own like tried to go to a
SoulCycle class I wouldn't go I wanted
to be held accountable and that's why I
kind of shared the entire journey with
everybody which is extremely not me like
I would like post videos of me working
on a tank top and I like to have not
shown my arms since the third grade so
you know I just really kind of started
to enjoy like Fitness health wellness
Matt who runs a live method and is my
trainer he put me on a macros plan and I
really focused on like diet sleep water
exercise and really it's like a
combination of like hit training and
weight training and like also a lot of
like cardio but not cardio on a machine
cardio like jumping jacks cardio like
burpees and things that I absolutely
hate but I really saw my body transform
so quickly and I like wanted to keep
going like I chose to go to class every
single weekend either Saturday or Sunday
at 10:00 or at 11 like I woke up I set
an alarm every weekend to go to class
because I really enjoyed it and I still
enjoy it I'm going back today at 3:30
like the journey is not over for me I'm
just gonna kind of change it up and do
it a little bit differently just because
I don't have as extreme of a goal as I
did for my wedding my next goal is
Jackie's wedding and then from there I'm
just gonna kind of set goals all year
long but I put so much effort into
getting into the best physical mental
emotional literal shape of my life for
my wedding that I don't want it to be a
one and done and honestly I went on my
mini moon I ate and drank everything I
wanted I think it was the first time in
my life that I wasn't like mentally on
diet you know like usually it's like oh
I shouldn't eat that or you know oh I'm
you know trying to be conscious or
trying to be low carb or this said and I
just like ate to my heart's content and
to be honestly I could not wait to come
home to just be like clean and healthy
again like I was so good yesterday and I
woke up today it's just so much of a
better feeling so I gained about 5
pounds since the wedding which you know
what great and now here we go again
um I have to talk about your shoes
because those are your wedding shoes and
I appreciate you wearing them for the
show
well someone wrote in the comment said I
should wear my dress which like was
unrealistic so I want to get a little
little some ya know we were thinking
like maybe your veil but this is perfect
and like you look cute and normal so you
wore these shoes for your party there is
Olivia special yes um
also you also look up the businesswoman
special um are you gonna wear them like
over this there's such a great shoe like
are you gonna wear them again oh you're
just wearing them today like for the
show so a great question um I have a
couple pairs of these Stella McCartney
shoes if not these some sort of other
version of a platform sneaker which
everybody knows I love these so I saw
them I was like oh my god I have to have
them and Zak wound up buying me them for
Hanukkah I came home one day and like it
was like the Friday before Hanukkah and
he was just so excited to give me them
that I opened the box and I was just
like overjoyed I literally slept with
them like next to my bed in the weeks
leading up to my wedding I brought them
on my mini moon with me I do plan to
wear them I think that they're more of
like a summery issue but I definitely
want to wear them and will wear them
they're so special to me they're super
cute they're great you just for life
yeah they're great you and I love them
and it's like it's so special that zach
got them for me because I love them so
much but you know what else that got for
me what we did 23andme
he bought us 23andme for Hanukkah we
both were supposed to do it together and
he hasn't not done his yet because he
says that it's too hard for him to go 30
minutes without eating or drinking and
it it is hard I do it when I'm in the
morning not only do you have to go three
minutes without eating or drinking but
then you have to like makes alive and if
it's like I'm thirsty right did he go to
23andme calm slash toast I actually
don't know if I'm sure he I feel like
I mean he might have CD so you did it
results I got my results would you like
to share with the class I would
I am 99.6% Ashkenazi okay so another one
who's not adopted or switched in the
hospital
yep so now we just have to do snitch but
I feel like no one is more of a Steen
than the snitch totally totally and now
but but sad cuz I mean I made Zack do it
and he just got his results back and as
you guys know I am 100% Ashkenazi Jewish
it's just so crazy just want to say like
literally direct descendants of Theo's
babushka in Russia and I made exactly
what cuz I was like if you you know if
you're like 25 like we have to talk
he is 99% Ashkenazi Jewish so we're one
definitely related and two gonna have
just such an awesome Jewish babies which
is just so fun if you want to find out
where you hail from or your partner
hails from check out 23andme 23andme
allows you to go beyond ancestry to
access more personal insights based on
your DNA from your health
predispositions to your lifestyle
choices so you can get a
lactose-intolerant report a caffeine
consumption report I should do that one
a muscle composition report a genetic
weight report that is so crazy and you
can buy your 23andme health an ancestry
kit today at 23andme calm / toast that's
the number two three and me.com slash
toast
again that's 23andme dot-com slash toast
I recommend that everyone do it it's
really it's net it's important to know
where you come from and we didn't know
where you're going so I um I did the
health you guys 25 streams that line if
you need it I did the health and
ancestry one which is so interesting it
just kind of like tells you all these
like weird things that you're
predisposed to that you know one of them
for me was that I'm predisposed to
having long ear lobes which like what
she do I do it said like the time that I
wake up naturally or that I should wake
up is like 8:42 which to be honest with
you for work like he's the time that I
wake up literally that's the time that I
get out of bed everyday it's like always
like 842 843 which is just there's so
many weird things that I was like damn I
want and then there were some that were
nuts that I was like mmm I don't know
about that but it also it's good to do
genetic testing too you can see like
what you are variant for and it's just
like the fact that you like
in one thing and then you get all this
information by yourself is so
interesting so interesting ok tell us
about the dress okay that it what what
were you looking for was it what you
expected the process greater so I have
never like envisioned myself in anything
and I think that that's just because one
I don't know my weight was like always
fluctuating and I you know I tend to
wear like black and flowy that's just
like my personality my style and what I
think looks best on me so we wound up
going to David's Bridal to just try on a
few different styles cuz I literally had
no idea what I wanted do I want poufy do
I want tight do I want this that in the
other um I knew that I didn't want poufy
that was literally the only thing I knew
but what I wound up realizing was with
the weight that I was losing that
something tighter actually looked a lot
better and I knew that I wanted sleeves
again haven't shown my arms since the
third grade but also wanted to have I
mean I did have a modest ceremony and
sleeves like that just so my style I
wear everything with yes so um I went to
David's Bridal I found kind of like the
style that I liked and literally my mom
found a dress on my heart her mom found
a dress online and was like I think this
would literally look perfect on you and
I was like hmm
let me try to find out if any store in
the city saw cease so the dress is Mori
Lee and Mori Lee hat does sell in New
York but pretty much every retailer that
I called was like we are not selling
that anymore we don't sell more leave we
don't saw that dress number blah blah
blah the only place that had it was this
place called RK Bridal which is on like
54th and 12th and essentially I went
there and I went for that dress I said
I'm here for this I'm getting married in
three months and I want this dress I
hadn't even tried it on yet I'm just
like how does sneaking suspicion and
basically the woman was like well I have
Brides here for 2021 like pretty much
making it seem like I wouldn't be able
to get anything and part of that is
because they don't really carry that
much in stock so it does take a couple
of months to even get the dress in and
she was basically like listen I had the
dress I have it in one size above what
you are and I have it in ivory which
after I tried it on I did try it on in
the white and I actually
like more of an ivory creamish color
better and I knew that I was going to
continue to lose weight so is gonna have
to do alterations regardless so I didn't
mind that it was one size up and I would
honestly always recommend people who
think that they're gonna lose a ton of
weight for their wedding I would
recommend literally going a dress size
up like don't go a dress size down the
size you think you're gonna be because
you can always alter yourself into it
versus like trying to take the seams out
doesn't work
so when to RK Bridal try it on the dress
the one dress I was like this is the one
knew it from literally a picture on the
internet which is just so crazy they
won't end up having it in stock it came
like less than a week later but they
told me that they wouldn't be able to do
alterations because they're the
alterations are like six to nine months
out I mean this place is like crazy
Bridal bill I mean and this is on the
crazy like can I say what like they were
so unhelpful yeah no they were I'd the
fact that like you got what you needed
and like they just it was not a right
place to be yeah it was like they
weren't very nice they were nice at all
they wound up being nicer because what
happened was because I was losing a lot
of weight I pretty much went for a dress
fitting every two weeks
my last fitting was like on December
like 22nd it was a two-and-a-half hour
fitting I tried on the dress they
tailored it I tried on the dress they
tell it it was like three different
times back and forth because I literally
had to get it steamed and get it picked
up in order to get it in time for New
Year's Eve they did a great job but he
did a great job what weren't nice what
wound up happening was they didn't have
any bottles of water so I got one from
the vending machine and then they said I
couldn't bring in a store they wound up
telling me the dress came in they were
like do you want alterations and I was
like well you told me you couldn't do
them they're like no like well squeeze
you in so it's just like everything they
say they do they don't do but I have to
say enough good things about them
because the end product is all that
matters and you looked great exactly and
so that is the story behind the dress so
that is the first time that I've shared
that my dress is Mori Lee and I've seen
some toasters posts that they think that
they're wearing the same dress as me so
if you're wearing more Lee we are twins
um so if you could now being here in
this moment go and give yourself advice
the day after you got engaged about
wedding planning what have you learned
and what would you tell yourself Oh
a hard question I don't really know to
be honest as you like I so enjoyed the
process and like loved every second of
it maybe because mine was very limited
stress and quick and fun and everything
about it just wound up working out thank
goodness the only thing I would say and
a lot of people told me this so I did
try to take advantage of it in the
moment is to just like try to be a bit
more in the moment to like at your
wedding at your wedding even in like the
week leading up to it and just like
realize how special of a moment it is
because that's like a time in your life
that is so significant for you and then
you move on to the next phase like
you'll never be engaged again you know
so I guess that's the best piece of
advice I could give everybody's
different so for me I just I loved it
question from Ali Malhotra your 10 days
in what has been the greatest moment
last ten days of being a married woman
oh my god so much it's like really the
best feeling in the whole world but also
doesn't feel any different like I can't
explain it it's just like we had the
best time together on our trip but like
we always have the best time together
but it was just like so special
everything just feels like special and
exciting and like new and fresh again
but at the same time nothing has changed
like I can't explain it it's like this
is gonna be the weirdest thing I've ever
said but it's like when you're dating
somebody or like even when you're
engaged right like you always like you
keep your crazy inside and it's like you
are lady and you're this and that and
it's like when you're married like if
you make a little burp like you're not
gonna get divorced do you know what I
mean it's like nothing like unless like
something a horrific horrible terrible
god forbid happens but like nothing like
nothing can go wrong like in the
relationship unless like something
drastic right you know I'm like
especially in this phase it's just like
it's just like you wake up every day and
it's like like elated you know and I
always like especially my relationship
exactly I just woke up like just so
happy but it's like I know
other level totally but we have so many
questions about the design of your
wedding what went into the planning and
orchestrating and those are really
questions for you and Josh so we're
gonna take a quick break we'll be right
back from Josh with Josh from Birch
events design and we'll be asking him
all of your logistical related questions
about the affair the affair to remember
we'll see you soon
you
welcome back to the morning toast
wedding extravaganza we are now joined
by Josh Murch events event designs your
one name wonder do you know for so long
that we were working together I didn't
know your last name and I didn't need to
that's so funny you're just Josh even in
my phone even my sisters are like Olivia
RA Claudia joy and you're just oh really
everybody from Birch is like Josh birch
Ilana birch Sarah research like you guys
don't have last names and then like in
the beginning when I was working with
the people from birch and like Alana who
was my day of person like messaged me on
Instagram and like had absolutely no
clue who she was like her last name oh
honey who is this like I thought was
just a random person and then like I put
two and two together but she will all of
you will forever be saved to my phone
yeah first last name that's crazy yeah
birch has kind of been in our identity
now I mean even my kids called himself
birch they want to change your name
legally they should because that's what
you are
yeah Josh Burt have you ever met his
kids no but I've heard you talk about
them you love them love them and they're
like mini Claudia Jackie's in the making
right so where to gosh it's the most
outrageous thing I've ever seen they
have so much spunk in so much like
possess an opinion and attitude and I
was like you have to cultivate that
because these kids are gonna be like
something some day that was verbatim
what you said you're like you need to
cultivate this I'm like you called
cultivate this one thing special that's
great well we're so excited to have you
on the show because you did Olivia's
wedding it was incredible we have some
photos that we were are going to show up
on the stream but kinda once he get back
to the beginning because you also
designed Claudia's weddings beautiful
howdy and we knew you through Claudia so
how did you and Claudia sync up um I
think one of my friends actually was my
partner in Caroline she was amazing she
called me up she said girls no jobs
getting married we should do her wedding
and I'm like whose girl with no job
sorry Claudia we love you very well but
at the time I was like screws girls no
job and she's like she's like what's
wrong with you and I was like I guess
everything so I jumped in looked at it
and she's like we should do this we'll
get along so well our personalities will
mesh which you know sure we'll discuss
but that's a huge part of the process
right right and then we linked up
someone reached out to Claudia Claudia
is like sure I'll give you a
let's meet we met and we became besties
I hope yes what was that and that was
before we were on a panel together that
was right it was it right before we were
right before like it was just put us on
the panel yeah in Sarah it's like behind
the scenes over here and she is like
Josh's right hand and she was my right
hand on the day of and she's like
everything but Josh and I were on a
panel together it was like an
entrepreneurship leadership Jewish
entrepreneurship and he was like nice to
meet you I'm doing your sister's wedding
I'm like oh my god that's so cool and
then like had a follow-up meeting a
month or two later I was like hi there
we were on a panel together and I barely
remembered I was just like that was such
a blur to me cuz like my first like
public thing and I was just like this
the whole time and I just like I want to
get it over with and everybody there was
so like powerful and I was like but now
you're a seasoned pro up here on the
toast okay so let's talk about the decor
for your wedding it is so beautiful what
was the inspiration behind it how did
you guys come to this design motif and
you know what were some of the things
that you really wanted to highlight and
focus on yeah well I will say one the
venue itself Russian Tea Room is so
gorgeous that like I'll let Josh really
talk about the date core stuff but like
so much of it was just like in the fact
that we wanted to really just elevate
the space and what was there the only
thing that I had sent to Josh was that I
wanted like oh branchy white chuppah and
that's it like I just sent a picture of
something that I found on the Internet
and I said this is the vibe I'm going
for for the hubba and that is literally
all I did and he did everything else
thank you listen I mean one of the
biggest things about designing a wedding
in general is trying to work with the
space either you're changing the space
that you're working with the space I
think in this case it was such a dream
for you to get married in the Russian
Tea Room and I think that was huge it's
my first time you know getting the
opportunity to work there and the room
has so much character that to change it
would have been such a like a waste and
then plus it's the character about it
that you love so much
right so all we did was really work with
it we tried to enhance it try to make it
a little bit more dressed up a little
more current a little bit more you guys
young and in love
and I think we did a job I think so tell
your ceremony came out pretty crazy
crazy favorite moment of the day by the
way crazy what are your thoughts on a
New Year's wedding had you ever done one
before - not New Year's wedding I've
done a lot of New Year's parties but the
wedding aspect was actually kind of fun
it was like oh my gosh it that terrible
you're not gonna have plans I'm like
what I mean these are the best plans
first of all hanging out with you guys
was like whoa the family is so fun the
whole crowd was fun yeah it was poppin
that party was poppin but it was great
it was it great it was a great event and
I was so happy to be there yeah it's fun
so you do a lot of New York City
weddings what are some of your favorite
spaces to work at in the city what do
you look for when looking for a venue
because there's the Russian Tea Room
which really is almost turnkey yes it's
the term they use but then you also do a
lot of like loft studio spaces that you
completely transform so what do you
think is the ideal scenario so I think
it really does depend depend on a couple
for us specifically we're always looking
for something that works well for you so
there are some people who want to get
married into your very iconic places
like the plaza the Pierre what used to
be the Waldorf you know the New York
Hilton you know you have all these
amazing places in New York and they have
tons of character and you sort of
embrace that and go with that old-world
elegance and ambiance and old-world
flowers and or you have the loft spaces
which are super cool too you know and
that for our from our perspectives like
let's transform like we're down to
change carpets and trade balls and
create new spaces and hang chandeliers I
mean we've discussed all this stuff
before and it was just like it really
does depend on a couple that's really
what it comes down to because we could
do anything what are some big trends for
weddings this year that you're seeing
and what are some and also what are some
wedding trends that you don't like that
like you think people will regret regret
um okay well I'll start with the first
ones it's not easier trends for this
coming year I think what people are
doing now is they're looking a lot more
for experiences in their wedding so it's
not just about you know putting
beautiful flowers on the table and
calling it a day I mean one of the
biggest conversations we had was like
even just about the cloth right
I don't obsess about clothes but I'm not
willing to sit back sometimes and say
hey let's just use menu cloth cuz that's
what they have because that really made
it transformative remember back to our
first conversation was like okay maybe
we'll do cream and then we'll just
embrace it and work with it and we're
like no let's go heavy
go let's go hard yes let's drive wish
for it yeah right the idea was is that
that sometimes you know you want to give
the guests a full immersive experience
that's really what it comes down to so
buy your wedding specifically you know
we had this whole idea of the ceremony
and the dinner was in the same room so
what happened was all the guests left
and then he came back to something that
was completely different and
transformative which is what made it
amazing and I think that's trending
going forward as well people are looking
for new experiences in their weddings
whether it's bringing an entertainment
whether it's getting a cooler band
whether it's having some amazing wall
behind the band or some ceiling
treatment that people aren't used to
seeing it's all about the experience now
that's a huge trend one of the things
that I think I'm not liking as much
don't hate me for this but it's like
there's a lot of this organic Ness
that's happening and I'm feeling like
it's slightly going a little bit more
old-world organics what do you mean but
I mean it's like you have a lot of these
natural natural designs right everyone's
ringing these woods which are really
great influence like succulents and
which is it works in certain spaces but
I think when you go into a New York City
venue which is harder when it's a lot
more opulent the idea of you know
getting a nicer space and going less Sun
decor doesn't really translate as well I
think it's the Pinterest effect the area
everything looks so good on Pinterest
you know all of these outdoor weddings
but if you're getting married at the
Plaza like you don't put a succulent in
there right but people would so I'm
saying like that bride should not choose
that venue yeah that's the one thing
that I'm saying I'm nothing against
organic weddings I like them I do them I
just it's not the it's not the ideal
situation for a New York City wedding
it's not the vibe no I would say no um
so Olivia a lot of those toasters have
been you know shook to the court Olivia
got married and indeed engaged married
three months you you know planned it all
so seamlessly what advice you have for
someone who is having a short engagement
like how long do you think that
engagements actually need to be in order
to plan a wedding is this go two ways so
from a bird's perspective we're gonna
say you get married we'll make it happen
just find a dress like literally as soon
as you can let's get married
like there's no stress in that like
designing an event
it takes time but we're gonna spend the
same 4050 hours designing it now and
working through it now as we will in
three months from now but in regards to
certain things you have venues which are
a lot more difficult and the dress the
dress is everything booking everything
else is slightly more simple interesting
imitations like you can choose your
invitation immediately if you're not
overly picky about it you can make that
decision one two three and you can move
on but getting a venue that's not locked
up for a date you want yeah thanks to
Lisa paper parfait little angel
yeah hearin pieces are beautiful but
like I just literally saw it online I
sent it to her I said can you make this
she came with her suitcase and all these
different paper samples we did this
sample that's humble that somehow I was
on your Bachelorette we were at the club
at 2:00 in the morning and she sent me
the proof and I was like not a hundred
percent sober and the monogram was
upside down because the way the envelope
flap closed and I was like the monogram
is upside down and she's like I know
that's how it's supposed to be and I was
like I need to get off my phone right
now but I literally made my invitations
in nine business days and she made them
overseas and look at that I mean you had
a three month engagement yeah we could
have shortened it by four weeks the
dress Wow okay another amazing how has
it been working with all the ashrae
sisters who has been the easiest
decision maker and who has been the
hardest in the sense that they take
forever to make a decision and yes I'm
gonna ask you to put two women against
each other and compare and contrast us
brides because you yeah at one point
we're working with both of us at the
same time yes so okay well you guys are
completely different I guess in terms of
all the offices too there's something
that you all do have and I actually
complimented each and every one of you
on it is that you guys are very
consistent you're a very very consistent
taste which is really easy to work with
because there are a lot of brides that
don't start saying that since everyone
is very definitive about to taste what
they like and what they don't like which
is amazing it makes our job so much
easier
the to compare you guys so olivia is
really boss like hardcore we're doing
this we're doing it right now this is a
decision we're gonna make it I'm gonna
make it today and if you don't answer
within the next 60 seconds I'm gonna
make the decision and then you're gonna
tell me that I should change it and then
I'm gonna let you it's like a hundred
percent boss and I think Jax
more like let's see the options let's
play with it a little bit more princess
and whimsical and I want it to be
prettier and it's a lot it's a lot more
of a fairytale and Olivia is a lot more
of a but it's not a business because I
don't want to take away from the fact
that her wedding was so magnificent and
you know it was magical your wedding but
so here's the thing I Sako he says this
to me - he's like why does everything
have to be done right now and I'm like
cuz it just does like that's just how I
am
so until it does a woman we didn't call
me yesterday you're like I need you to
make a decision on this right now and it
was done in 60 seconds yeah 190 right
but he said to me like at one point I
was like when do you need my table list
cuz we did like two long tables at all
at assigned seating and I was like can I
get it to you Monday and he was like
honestly if you could get it to me by
like Friday that would be better he's
like you always expect us to do
everything in 60 seconds so like maybe
you can - and I was like oh my god it
was so funny I was like wow you're right
okay I have to do unto others as they
have I wasn't taking tips um Olivia the
whole time I'm like this is how I need
to rule my life like now now now now now
everything's right now and I'm like okay
fine boss life like so from a design
perspective like when you are doing a
wedding what do you think are really the
most important elements like that have
to that you really should invest in okay
memorable moments are probably the most
important thing so people get caught up
in my opinion on I don't wanna take away
from details details are very important
they're awesome for your pictures it
really depends on how you're spending
your money also like it always comes
down to finances right so for me it's
the way that I look at it is you always
have to put your money where people will
remember it sometimes a cocktail hour
isn't the best place to invest your
money because it's literally 45 minutes
everyone's crowded into a room there's
highboys cocktails and there's a bar and
all people care about is drinking right
so I wouldn't spend money there unless
you're doing like that one photo out
moment in that space that people can
crowd around and take care of and I will
just touch on that and say that we did
not do one element of dellmore in our
cocktail hour yeah literally just the
tables the cost that they had and like
where we chose to invest
really in the food and the food crystal
Plaza like it was the most delicious
food ever and people were just like
loving the food just loving talking to
people and going to the bar and getting
a drink and like the room itself was
obviously gorgeous and that was part of
you know doing it at a venue that the
space was not a space you transform but
we do not spend there was literally not
one flower at the top zero and it worked
out really well yeah so to go back to
your questions just created spend your
money and spend your efforts and your
time on memorable moments so for a bride
on a budget where should they cut
corners and where should they never cut
corners oh that's a good one I think
never cut corners in the reception don't
that's the part to people remember the
most I think create as much party as
much Wow as possible in that space and
then for your ceremony sometimes well a
lot of times you can get away with
simple elegance understated elegance a
little bit more bespoke
a little bit more elegant and clean and
I think people feel like that the heaven
leanness about the ceremony as opposed
to just like what's decor like can I
touch upon something there
I also think the other really important
thing where I would recommend you spend
your money is on lighting yes lighting
transforms a room I went to a really
beautiful wedding not that long ago like
one of Zach's friends and it was like so
beautiful but like just the lights wrong
and I was like oh my god like I just
wish there was a little bit of like mood
lighting in here and like when I look at
the photos from my wedding like our
first dance like the lighting that Jimmy
did what dynamic vision like it was
there was like roses on the floor which
was kind of obviously everything was a
red rose in the venue and also my
invitation was like a laser cut kind of
like Rose print so all like tides so
nicely together and like I never I mean
I'm sure you went through lighting with
him but like I never spoke to him I
never told him what I wanted like that
was all on you and you were the one that
was like lighting is really important
they need to do this and I think
actually this is just how good of a guy
this guy is but he lives in Florida he
stayed in New York on New Year's Eve
just to do the lighting at my wedding
just like what a great guy and he did a
fantastic job and the lighting for me
was so memorable I love that I love that
I don't even know how I didn't remember
that hey mommy so Liv you had predicted
that Zacks friends we're gonna be the
most turnt
now you were there and touch you were
there and you actually might be the best
person to ask because you you know we're
sober the most turned well I was also
sober I did not drink I have one glass
of champagne right after that day I
wanted to remember every moment because
it was so special and like I was aware
of every minute that happened there
that's a good piece of advice for people
I would say like turnt is so different
than like amazingly fine and Mike has
turned is like throwing up you know
right amazingly like the winner the
winner of just all-around like got the
best drunk I would say was Weinreb I was
gonna say this just killed it was ideal
oh no no but here's the thing before
Mike had nothing great support knighting
had nothing to do with being turned 419
is the newest thing in simply dancing
I'm jolly it's sweeping it was doing
that dead like it was so great and like
I started to do it and then Claudia
starts doing everybody was doing it and
it was like it was I can't even
I'm an outsider's perspective like we're
the Phantom of phantoms of the party
right so we're like sitting in the
background watching this all happen
living vicariously through your
excitement I swear when Claudia started
dancing I lost that because you guys
together first of all that crazy like
unity that you had everyone was so into
it like we were dancing we're like we're
doing the same thing on the side we're
just dying we're like my favorite was
that Claudia took the mic from the band
Oh My pretty much had it the entire time
and they turned the mic off so that she
couldn't sing but that she could pretend
she was singing I think they turned it
on for one song but wait so they do
their customer like before it even all
started and it was so so so so fun some
point to just yeah ban was so on point
around town entertainment which was so
funny because talking I know one of the
questions is was there anything that I
had to forego because I did sure
engagements yeah and so typically
Claudia had element music Mary Ann
Bennett as will you she's amazing but
she was not available and so I really
like I spent most of my time just doing
research on the band and I found a round
town entertainment and no one I had
known had ever used them and but the
videos of them were so amazing and the
guy was like so like on it and great to
work with he's like we've been in the
business for 15 years don't worry about
anything and I'm like all right and
basically they were the only thing that
I was a tad unsure about just because I
did not know anything about them they
had sent a very long list of references
that you guys like double check for me
but you know at the end of the day like
I didn't know any of those references
they weren't personal references and
like if they were me were just like I
couldn't believe it we were shocked they
were so good I didn't believe it because
the only like trickiness as it related
to the wedding was that we did it on New
Year's Eve and Russian Tea Room is on
57th Street which is predominantly a
street that is closed because of the New
Year's Eve Ball Drop and basically from
the day that I knew that I was getting
married there I was in touch with the
NYPD Community Affairs hi I'm having a
wedding here what do I have to do to
make sure people can cross and get
through
I got a room block for all the people
coming in from out of town like
literally next door to the venue I
wanted to make people's lives as easy as
possible knowing that it was New Year's
Eve and so basically I worked with NYPD
and the invitations lady to make an
insert that basically said hi I'm going
to a wedding here here's my little posse
that lets me go through and I think the
band was having a little bit of trouble
understanding that like they couldn't
they couldn't just like come and go as
they please because it was New Year's
Eve and it became a little bit of a
cringe-worthy situation but they wound
up being so fine and they never closed
the street nope Street it never closed
big change it up every year for security
precaution and it's like you don't want
to like know what but I also think it
because it was raining yeah there
weren't as many people so they didn't
close the street and not one person had
problem getting to the wedding I don't
even think people needed to use their
answer I use my answer I'm really I'm so
glad every time I had to go back and
forth to the hotel through the back
streets was 56 was closed got it so
every time we need
loading that was a load in it was much
harder like I was there at like 8:00 in
the morning fighting with the security
with what the police officer and the
Russian Tea Room was there as well and
we're like sitting there like we have
access to the street like here the
passes and he's like I was told by 8:00
a.m. were closed and then he extended to
9:30 and then we're like we just get
like like there's only one person coming
down a spot it's just anyone for this
wedding just let us in it took us a long
time but we got it yeah well speaking of
the band um when we spoke about this
before songs that you know or do not
play that wedding I'm curious what you
think are like the worst wedding songs
and also some of the best ones oh I
can't answer this question this question
is very difficult number one I'm not
believe it or not so particular with
music it's shockingly enough it's one of
those elements that I just don't think I
don't feel strongly in I I get into it
but I but I would say like it depends on
you crowd like some of our clients like
in some of the brides that we meet are
like all about the oldies and some
people are very about what's current and
some people are very about like just
playing crazy DJ music at their wedding
I'm like it varies on your taste so like
I know you ladies are all up about the
music now the conversations that they
have that music is like wow like really
in a good way because you're into it
which I love and I mean we've
experienced it personally where we've
gone and we've heard singers and we've
heard stuff which is so fun yeah it's a
great part of the experience but like
right the reality is that that's not
your forte life or time well you know
what is so funny is that at my wedding
they played hey-yah and when it started
I was like Oh remember [ __ ] now this was
like this I definitely did not say like
this song can be played at my wedding
and the thing was is that like when you
have these songs that like I would never
listen to it on Spotify like right now
but at a wedding where everybody knows
the words and it's like so familiar like
I have such a distinct memory of hey yo
at my wedding being the most lit moment
from the dancefloor and like so I don't
think wedding music like it can't can't
go wrong even if they played a song that
like I wouldn't want to hear it's like
if everybody knows the words and you
know it's so overplayed on the radio and
whatnot but I had a wedding it just like
it works anything really works doesn't
that tie into the whole Commerce
Trusteer vendors yes yeah you have to be
able to work with people that you feel
are going to provide the product you
looking for that's a number one piece of
advice I can get that's a number by the
way that's the same piece of advice I
give for people when they're going on
job interviews it's literally all about
how you feel ya talking to the person
it's not about your skill set because at
the end of the day like anybody can
learn anybody can make anybody can do
it's like how do you drive with that
person that is it if you like from the
second you meet them have like a weird
contentious relationship like you feel
awkward or you're afraid to ask them if
you stop for something
I literally just run for the hills it
actually happened to me with my makeup
because I got referred to a makeup girl
we were supposed to do a trial she
literally canceled on me three times she
kept saying she was coming and then she
was in traffic and she couldn't blah
blah blah I had really wanted Priscilla
who does all the Housewives to do my
makeup and I was kind of at my wit's end
with this lady who kept canceling on me
and I was like I just got a really bad
vibe from this like I don't know and I
had texted Priscilla like the third time
this woman canceled and she was like I'm
available and I was like oh my god done
goodbye
didn't do a trial didn't do anything
just like trusted it and went with it
that's the best piece of advice and give
anybody I don't know if it's one of the
questions but like if I had to you know
turn to any persons getting engaged or
getting married and say what's your best
piece of advice it would be you have to
work with people that you trust because
at the end of the day every contract
reads the same I'm gonna come and do
your face to make up right or I'm gonna
give you a short rib or I'm gonna give
you a bowl of white flowers well a bowl
of white roses well it's my bowl of
white roses and we could actually speak
about this regarding the Rose concept
right your proposal said a table full of
red roses you didn't know how was gonna
be made exactly you didn't know how many
I was gonna put it's a conversation like
every proposal could read exactly the
same a table of red roses and candles
how many are you doing 500 are you doing
100 are you doing 50 it's the same
wording but in my mind I edit it one way
and in the next class and the next
company's Monday I did it a completely
different way so you have to trust the
editing and the product that the
person's gonna give out just like we can
literally share this he sent me a PDF it
was two slides and it said Papa branches
white lights big or something like that
with a picture
reception with a picture from Google
though webinar and then reception yeah
long tables red flowers candles another
inspiration Victor inspiration picture
and that's it there wasn't literally
nothing else and that's why I was so I
mean I knew the wedding was gonna be
gorgeous and like I just trusted you but
like when I saw it I couldn't believe it
was my wedding like it was it was ten
times more beautiful than I even thought
it was gonna be like I had high
expectations I set the bar high for
myself I set the bar high for people
that I work with I set the bar high when
I'm spending money on anything but like
oh my god and the fact that you guys
captured my face every time that
elevator door open like favorite moments
of the day elevator opening Olivia going
like this I couldn't believe it and even
Zack Zack mr. allergy allergic to
flowers wanted no flowers at the wedding
like oh he was he kept saying the whole
time he's like you know like a wedding
is really for the bride it's really for
the bride you know he wasn't involved in
the wedding planning process and it was
so funny because after the wedding he
texted his friend and he said were a
piece of advice the wedding is for you
too and he said as he was walking down
the aisle he realized that it was as
much for him as it was for me and he was
like so overjoyed about all of it and
that was like so special to me cuz the
whole time I kept saying I'm like this
is for us and he just kept saying like I
just want to get married on the side of
the road and I'm like yeah but when we
get married on the side of the road what
road is it gonna be and what are you
gonna wear and who from our families are
gonna be there and how are people gonna
sin and what's the probably gonna do I
mean like even if you get married on the
side of the road you get married if
Russian tearoom like there's things to
do and like I was always doing things
because I like to do things I mean the
second the wedding ended I didn't even
know what to do with myself I started
making like spreadsheets of all the
gifts people got me and you know
tracking when the thank yous were coming
and my registry about I would just I
have to always be doing stuff and he
always kept saying why you tinkering
with this why I get tinkering with that
and I'm like go away like this is what I
do but then when we got there and he
like he felt it so much too and like
that I think was one of the most special
parts for me especially when you said
that he walked down the aisle and he's
like this is just as much for me as it
is heard of it he texted us the next day
or so yeah he's really so cute um
question for you we have some people
we're interested birch events obviously
does incredible things and are you
hiring and what's the best way to go
about getting a job at birch Wow
first of all we're always looking for
cool fun young people always my my
hiring process is very different than
most people's I don't necessarily hire
for talent I hired based on personality
if you didn't get a job I mean it
doesn't mean I didn't like you maybe the
position was available I'm just saying
but the reality I just don't want anyone
[Laughter]
there yeah just didn't I just didn't get
along with you no ma'am you just didn't
want to be around you every day that's
what it is
this becomes a family so like you have
to really get along with people I mean I
don't know why any of the people that
work with me work with me I'm like
shocked they're like not my blood and
they still put up with me but the
reality is is that I like when people
come in most of my team has interned by
me for a substantial amount of time with
no pay to experience process and the
reason why I do that is strictly because
I don't believe a lot of the people that
want to go into this industry can really
handle it yeah it's a very hard business
it's a very driven business it's
something that you have to always be
emotionally prepared for because Brides
get crazy in just a matter of it
the groom's get crazy the parents get
crazy all for different reasons some our
financials some because they don't love
the design some because they can
envision and you have to be able to
capture all that coddle it deal with it
and still deal with the details of
preparing for a wedding at the same time
yeah and a boss like me can I also say
that that's so true and Sarah who works
for you love Sarah on the day of my
wedding she was like the person on the
band because she knew that I the band
was the only thing as a little pit
worthy and we did our first look in the
rain and when I came we like we're
touching up and she's like I used to do
hair let me help you and I'm like okay
so you used to work in music you used to
do hair like what don't you do but like
now you do events and it's like to your
point if you're not hiring based on
skill set you're hiring based on
personality oh and she just happens to
be like a triple threat and can
literally do everything it's what you
it's what you get like the reality is
when Sarah came on board she did the
same thing everyone else does she
interned by me forever she had everyone
in the country call me to like make sure
I hired her after
it's just really harassing but it worked
Oh clearly she's really into it so like
she was able to do a bunch of things and
she was also kind of within the industry
she knew what it was like to deal with
service we aren't in the service
business it's what we do yeah you know
we are besides a beauty there's so many
companies that create beauty and all
beautiful things but like the one thing
that changes burch a little bit is that
our experience is slightly better yes
and can I just also add to that I did
not have a wedding planner right like it
was just me and Burch and we from the
very beginning when I met with Josh I
was like do I need a day of person he's
like no he's like my team will help you
do all of it yeah and do decor and
honestly best decision I ever made not
to say that you shouldn't have a wedding
planner you should definitely have a day
of person and but birch served as day of
and as decor for me we share but from
everything you've said you were your
wedding planner so I wouldn't typically
say for everyone to do that it happens
to be one we know the families so well
right and we went through this already
with Claudia so like we knew what to
expect going into it also was a very it
was an intimate wedding I tell you while
I was there at my wedding it felt like
there were 300 you know it really did
I couldn't leave hundred felt so big it
was insane because everyone's so in love
with each other yeah you don't
understand was like on the outside too
looking at you guys it was such a warm
wedding oh what a great way to have your
wedding described okay so I have one
more question we have some more photos
that are gonna pull up on the stream and
regarding photos and design yeah and we
asked Anthony Vasquez the same question
because I just think it's so interesting
but has Instagram changed and this whole
you know photo culture has it changed
the way that you design weddings and has
it shifted the focus of certain things
because you know that you know this is
the Instagram moment like do you have
Instagram in the back of your mind when
designing a wedding I mean obviously you
crush Instagram the Burt adverse events
design has the most coordinate Instagram
total the photos that are coming up on
the street now are just so beautiful
they capture the essence of the design
and the couple and I just I'm curious
what your Instagram strategy is because
obviously social media hashtags are a
huge part of weddings correct
so yes the answer is yes Instagram has
changed everything
social media has changed everything but
it also really adds just a lot of stress
and anyone who is in the design world
knows this is because almost like what
fashion used to be
I mean factually I was even faster than
it ever was right but they always have
to be ahead of trend so like I'm
designing a wedding today and it's and
it's
I don't know purple and it's gonna be
the most unique purple wedding anyone's
ever seen because I'm going 100% purple
and then like a day later someone in
Istanbul creates a purple wedding just
because purple there is more common and
they created like this incredible
wedding from it and now it's everywhere
it's a viral everyone's going crazy
about this purple wedding my wedding is
in a week like now what am i the copycat
I've been planning this for six months
okay so it's like it's a little bit it's
a little bit stressful when you go on
like every night like you go on
Instagram you're looking at everyone's
work all these amazing designers you
know like please don't have what I'm
thinking in my head today because we're
all sort of like inspired by the same
things whether it's fashion or
architecture or just design in general
or just being outside and seeing one
thing that's beautiful in you transform
it again the trends you know sort of
shift in a certain way but we always
have in the back of our head what is
Instagram going to love and the pictures
are really everything we sit back before
anything's done on an event and
literally Allen is like sitting there
like taking a picture of it and saying
will this photograph well and that's all
he cares about so what will it
photograph well yeah so yes 100% yes
Instagram has shifted the way that we
think the way that we design we're
looking for those moments where guests
can take pictures in front of and
everyone wants it because everyone wants
that moment that's like this was my
wedding and it was the most beautiful
picture and that's why Bert you actually
got known for the bathroom thing you
know there's like a new shtick
I love it I love going crazy in
bathrooms on floral because everyone
wants a bathroom selfie that's so true
copy me I'm kidding I'm joking how would
you see it you'll know they copy Bert's
but that isn't true I'm always taking
like a mirror pic bathroom if there's a
little something if for me
that's everything because I feel like
every woman and every guy goes to the
bathroom and just like if this bathroom
overflowing the flowers you're like holy
crap then you don't have to have a photo
booth right like I have a photo but I
did not feel like I missed it whatsoever
you're right yeah oh you didn't have a
photo that was so interesting any photo
that anybody took in the space was like
beautiful and gorgeous and was like it
it served as its own photo but not
everyone has the luck of having such an
intimate space that was fully mirrored
so everywhere you looked like you saw
you know at the table or these like
experiences like what I loved about my
wedding was so many people posted photos
under the HIPAA after we left like there
was literally a line to take a picture
under the hope as if it was like a
flower wall can we discuss the stress of
that though because I had to turn over a
room in half an hour like all your
guests are waiting online to take
pictures on this ceremony and I'm like
guys I okay okay oh my god I might be
back and I'm like I'm breathing away and
house is like Olivia will kill me if we
go one minute over 920 it's not gonna
work
we went nine minutes over 1 1 9 20 but
whatever so much they like didn't even
care the cocktail hour seemed to me oh
my god the food is so good so he ate so
much mess so tightly you looked
fantastic but like once I walk down the
aisle I was like I don't care if I have
a little gut like whatever totally can I
ask you a question sure but wait I just
emailed a picture that were gonna add to
the stream it's like probably a picture
that really captures the the essence of
the night perfectly Jake I just sent it
to you um so I'll give you a minute and
then you can ask me something and then
we'll post it and just a great way to
end the show but fantastic well I feel
like you know my Bridal time is coming
to an end we're on to miss Jackie oh so
like what I expect from you I mean the
world we're obviously gonna do like so
many different episodes and whatnots but
your invites just went out inmates just
went out there honestly I'm not gonna
lie they're stunning
there's John Mayer taking the world by
storm II Webster and I did it all myself
like in my own head you know what I mean
like of thinking of it like so I just
want all the credit yeah you deserve it
let me tell you something I've seen a
lot of brides do invitations and they're
not great I mean okay but okay I worked
with by invitations who just they were
able to execute it so perfectly totally
and I was just so happy with it and I
know like Josh was so skeptical about
like when I told him what I was thinking
yeah it was it's scared of my big fake
fat a happy face like yay that's gonna
be great and I'm like we'll wait for her
to develop the process more and then
we'll tell her that
not a good idea but you developed it and
you developed it flawlessly it was so
pretty and when you showed it to us in
the office we opened it up were just
like this is what you were thinking done
right I don't to give away too much even
I know you guys have been showing it on
social but a little bit you've been you
did it right yeah it was really correct
thank you very much so I yeah and they
definitely helped us because like I
reported this week Zach and I were going
to wedding design therapy because we
couldn't agree on a color an issue that
exists everywhere in our lives but we
had to finally choose something so we
sat down with you guys the invitation
helped Saracen in direction and I'm just
like so excited about what we have
planned and it's actually what our first
idea was we got off track for like one
reason or another but now we're back to
the region idea and I just think it'll
be so perfect for the venue for the time
of year and for us as a couple because
it's it's not gonna be super feminine or
super masculine it's very you guys which
I'm very excited to translate it's gonna
be a fun translation of a couple into a
very you know an epic wedding yeah I
think so weird if you like I think we're
totally opposite Brys cuz you're like on
top of everything stripped stress-free
like you live for it for the to-do list
yeah and for me like everything stresses
me out so like I'm just so excited for
it to be here like not for it to be over
for my wedding to be here I'm excited
for my wedding day I'm gonna be the most
relaxed bride like if anything goes
wrong like I do not give a [ __ ] like a
shred of a [ __ ] but why cuz there's
nothing cuz I don't stress about stuff
that I can't control
right just things that go wrong it's
like that's part of the process like
that was meant to go wrong and the X Y Z
was meant to happen it's like you can't
even think about it as a thing to go
wrong but I think I just realized what's
so different about me and you you are so
like you're very fashionable and stylish
Tan Dun like I feel like from the design
perspective like you like you have so
much more of a say of what you want and
like for me I'm I'm like okay what do
you think is best and then like to your
point of like just do the to-do list
like I'll do the details and you do the
big stuff and you're all about the big
stuff it's very funny yes yeah that's
where you guys differs yes yeah very
cool
yeah okay well this has been incredible
we have one more photo to show you it's
a picture that was taken at 12 o'clock
midnight
at Olivia's wedding so if you look
around like everyone is kissing just
being so cute and it just perfectly sums
up like the vibe of the evening and the
mood and and the beauty of the New
Year's wedding done by virtue events
design and this is the essence of that I
said I want New Year's to be crazy can
we do confetti and they were like we got
it like I did not know the specifics of
like what the you know what's the stuff
like the glasses and the Hat like all
this stuff I didn't really know anything
I was just like I want a moment at New
Year's and they said great done and that
was like I feel like for you you would
like plan the like essence of the colors
and the experience to a tee and I was
just like well at 1159 who's lining up
with you know but like not what are you
lining up with just like where are you
standing yes that's where I'm like nuts
yeah but I was just like I want a big
moment take that and run with it well
you guys made so many big moments Thank
You Josh for everything you do to help
us thank you for coming on the show
thank you for explaining for the
toasters we're can everyone follow you
and the amazing work that you and your
company do so you could follow us at
birch event design birch event design
and on our website also have events calm
but pretty fun designs updated like
daily content you could just see us it's
going like this all day
oh yeah it's just you and your team per
usual have you changed your handle yet
is there any place we should follow yeah
I haven't changed my handle yet and I'm
debating on what to do with the whole
name changing process and just I think
their handle should be Olivia Oz Shapiro
well I still have that reserved so you
should make them it could potentially be
changing soon but for right now Olivia
ASHRAE I you know nothing like upcoming
is going to be that significant other
than my workout so like I just feel like
people should patiently wait until your
wedding and just like all the photos all
the flow that will roll out from there
because I can only venture to guess how
good the photos will be for I'm really
focused on my flow and I've said it so
many times to Josh like the flow when
you click the hash tag like I want the
flow to be pop in like I want to send
everyone a preset that they need to use
I was gonna are you sending a preset to
Anthony Vasquez no but I literally or
like if my friends are taking pictures
like I wanna be like oh just airdrop
that to me I'll just edit it for you
real quick
because sometimes the way people edit
photos like scary wild like horrific
what about instead of a photobooth you
have like an editing booth where people
like go and share photos like so just
like edit on the spot and then they get
very oh my god I'm big house like
someone emails their photo and they get
it sent back like the way that it should
be in the theme of the wedding or they
just joined to it for the toast they
post it to the group
they make it premium and then the only
problem with that is that when you
upload it to Facebook it's not as
high-res so the email aspect I think or
airdrop like just get another phone that
like someone sends a photos know that I
just got super complicated super
complicated the details I don't want to
worry about it up I'll take it on for
you Jackie okay thank you all for tuning
into the longest show ever I hope you
all have an amazing weekend I have to go
take care of my nephews me chest
thank you guys both so much you
congratulations on just a wonderful
wedding and a job well done we will see
you all on Monday back with Claudia
you